[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and i was right
i was right i told you
i look i didn't want to say i told you
so but
i did didn't i so i just recently made a
video showing you guys the huawei mate
xs one of the sexiest folding phones
out maybe the sexiest
but my conclusion was okay it's hot i
like this a lot
but it's not practical and so maybe we
should stop the whole folding over the
outside thing until the tech gets a
little bit better
then we'll come back to it so now here
we have the huawei mate x2 brand new
just got announced and i've got my hands
on it and as you can see
they've done the thing they've gone from
an outside fold to an inside folding
display so now it's doing a lot of
things really similarly to samsung
z-fold 2 which i reviewed and really
liked but there's actually a couple
things here that are different that make
this the best folding phone hardware out
right now so first of all this outside
screen it's even bigger and higher
quality than samsung's to the point
where it actually feels like a
full-fledged smartphone and i know we
were just saying that about the z-fold 2
because it was so much better than the
first fold and that's poor excuse for a
front screen but the mate x2 clearly
beats out the fold too and it's no
contest it's a full 6.45 inch diagonal
so it's actually pretty huge and it's
wider so it's much closer to a normal
aspect ratio it's 2700 by 1600 oled with
thin bezels and a 90 hertz refresh rate
plus they've given it a 240 hertz touch
sample rate this looks
like a normal smartphone when i'm
holding it it doesn't quite feel like
one still because of course it's still
twice as thick and the fingerprint
reader is on the bottom half as the
power button
and obviously it's not quite just like a
normal phone but the goal is to remove
as many trade-offs as possible and
that's what they're all trying to do
here but yeah look at that just looks
just like a normal smartphone especially
with that aspect ratio close to it
anyway a quick word on that selfie
camera though so you can see it's a
double
wide pill shape cut out there so you
have the selfie camera itself and then i
believe
a time of flight sensor next to it
which i bet they thought a lot about on
a phone like this because that
time-of-flight sensor is good for giving
you a little bit of better depth
information and potentially better focus
now if i just want to hop on a random
video call or just take a quick selfie
i just use the regular camera i don't
need that it is cool to have autofocus
in a selfie camera don't get me wrong
the time-of-flight sensor helps with
that
but i feel like if i actually care about
an accurate portrait mode and the depth
information i'm doing more than just a
regular selfie well then on a phone like
this i can open up the phone and use the
incredible high quality cameras on the
back and take a way better selfie photo
portrait mode videos all that stuff will
be great so i was just thinking when i
saw this they probably could have left
it out and just done a regular small
cutout for the selfie camera
but obviously having faster autofocus
for a camera like this like they did in
the p40 pro plus
is a nice bonus so not a huge deal cool
to have the point is this outside screen
being a way closer to traditional 15 by
9 aspect ratio makes it way more usable
than any other outside screen on a
foldable phone it's a major strength of
this mate x2 now when you go on the
inside
that's where you get your uninterrupted
8 inch display uninterrupted because
there's no selfie camera cut out at all
and it's really nice it's also 90 hertz
which is pretty good it's an 8 to 7.1
aspect ratio so nearly square and
there's hardly any crease at all i am
very very impressed by how well this
display and hinge combine to minimize
the look and feel of any crease down the
middle now it's definitely still there
it's not totally gone and you can see it
at the most extreme viewing angles but
it's actually much better than samsung's
fold and this hinge like really nicely
firmly pops the phone open to flat this
is a good one
that is a good
hinge right there it's a good hinge
shout out to the hinge
engineers the engineers of course um
also when it's closed it actually uh
it's closer to flat and and flush with
the back of the phone so it doesn't
really protrude as much if you note in
the z fold two it kind of protrudes out
the side a little bit and when you're
holding it
you feel like you're holding more of
that hinge so it is impressive that they
also managed to squeeze it further into
the phone body itself feels less
obtrusive that way but then there is one
especially wild thing about this phone
and you might have noticed it by now in
the footage but it's
it's a wedge shape look at this it's a
wedge going from the thinnest all the
way on the left 4.4 millimeters
all the way to the thickest heaviest
part on the right hand side and that is
of course intentional huawei's got their
reasoning for it which is it feels
better in the hand so hear me out or
hear them out they argue that with
phones like the z-fold because the
center of gravity is further from your
hand when you hold it that little bit of
wobble feels extra heavy like there's a
lot of weight really far from your hand
and that's what makes the phone feel
heavy so by putting more of the weight
closer to your hand the center of
gravity is now closer to where it would
be in a normal phone and the thinner
lighter bit that's outside
feels
lighter
and i buy that i really do i feel like
this phone feels less heavy it is still
overall a pretty heavy phone but you can
tell it feels different in the hand when
it's open and i think that feels better
than the z-fold too it's nice now when
it is closed it's got this slanted mid
line that's kind of funny but that's
totally fine it still goes pretty much
flush protects the inside screen and
really the only possible downsides of
this particular shape is it rocks a lot
on a table thanks to the big camera bump
but you know it's just annoying it's not
a deal breaker a lot of phones rock
but also the total combined battery size
is 4 500 milliamp hours which is a
little bit small for something with this
much screen it is funny though it is
it's very tempting to just give this
phone the foldable phone
hardware
crown like straight away just because
even more so than samsung they are using
very close to their flagship bits and
specs
inside this phone it's already the 90
hertz much bigger better display on the
outside it's already a better like hinge
design but also this mate x2 actually
has just about the same camera system as
their top end p40 pro plus or mate 40
pro plus which are really good cameras
that's a 50 megapixel gigantic one over
1.28 inch primary camera you've got a 3x
telephoto and a 10x periscope zoom lens
and a slightly downgraded ultrawide but
then it's still got a fairly advanced
speaker system that pairs a driver at
the top with one at the bottom for a
pretty wide stereo sound as a bonus
and yes they've put some pretty beefy
specs inside too so kieran 9000 chip 8
gigs of ram 256 gigs of storage it's 5g
capable it's got wi-fi six it's just
overall a very high-end piece of
hardware in a lot of ways it does
55-watt fast charging with the charger
that
comes in the box which is pretty nice it
could potentially i mean i haven't used
this phone long enough to review battery
life but it could potentially offset
the concerningly small 4 500 milliamp
hour battery because it's a 8 inch 90hz
display and a high-end chip
no wireless charging though that is a
bummer but overall i am very impressed
with this phone as a piece of hardware i
gotta say now the software situation is
the same as the first mate x which means
no google app support
and this one it's not coming to the us
or anything i just wanted to get my
hands on it to test it but i just i
appreciate it for how impressive and
cutting edge
this piece of hardware is to me though
i'm keeping this in the back of my head
every time i see and get to test a new
folding phone which is
the end game for folding phones
is you want to get it as close to just
another feature as possible they want to
remove as many caveats
of having a folding phone as they
possibly can a lot of the first gen ones
it was really cool that they folded in
half but they weren't really a great
idea in a lot of other ways
but eventually if they can get it to be
just as usable without folding and just
as good of a battery life and just as
good specs and cameras and all that
stuff and the folding in half part is
just another feature
and the price is pretty close to the
same as regular phone that's when people
will start to want them so yeah this
phone to me
it's a step towards that it's got a
great outside screen obviously it's a
little bit short on battery but a lot of
the high-end specs really great cameras
and just a really refined maybe that's
the word a refined experience really
nice hinge
so i like it a lot it's on its way we'll
get back to the outside fold stuff later
either way
that's been it thanks for watching i'll
catch you guys the next one
peace
[Applause]
[Music]